so we've known for a while that the
Trump State Department was planning to
lift sanctions on three Russian
companies that are controlled or
influenced we can say by this Russian
oligarch and Putin crony Oleg Deripaska
the three companies are euro sippin ergo
UC ruse all and the en Plus group like
en plus sign group Deripaska is not just
a Putin crony he's actually said that he
doesn't even really see himself as
separate from the Russian state for the
purposes of a lot of international
discussions and and sort of frameworks
and he's also represented the Russian
government in other countries so this is
a guy who is not the Russian government
but is almost like the Russian
government there were members of both
the Republican and Democratic parties
who were against easing sanctions on
these three companies but the Trump
administration insisted they're doing
this they're dropping these sanctions
more favoritism towards Russia not a big
surprise in and of itself but now this
particular deal is even more rancid and
putrid because right after sanctions
were lifted one of those three companies
I mentioned to en+
said hey we're adding seven new
directors to our board and one of those
7 new directors happens to be total
coincidence
Christopher Bancroft Burnham who just
happens to have been a member of Donald
Trump's transition team the world
population roughly seven-and-a-half
billion the number of companies on our
planet I mean depends on how you measure
and what you include but one estimate is
that there are 200 million companies on
planet Earth and it just so happens that
days after the Trump administration
dropped sanctions on three Russian
companies one of those three companies
hires a Trump transition team member to
be on their board when this happens it
tells Vladimir Putin keep interfering
keep doing what you're doing because
you're winning big Lee with your
strategy and at this point I don't even
know if it's worth me saying it's
possible that
is just a coincidence like is that
necessary or is it pretty damn clear
that this simply is not a coincidence at
this point and it actually gets even
more insane with this guy because
Burnham also is a former vice chairman
at Deutsche Bank asset management and
co-founded and lead Deutsche Bank's
direct private equity group which now we
know is number one
Deutsche Bank is connected to Trump
records from Deutsche Bank were
subpoenaed by Robert Muller and this is
also connected to former Supreme Court
Justice Anthony Kennedy through his son
remember when we announced the
retirement of Justice Anthony Kennedy
and we told you at the time that it came
as a surprise even to the other Supreme
Court justices which is unusual usually
before a public announcement is made a
Supreme Court justice will tell their
colleagues that they plan to announce
their retirement and then we found out
by the way that Anthony Kennedy's son
was connected to Deutsche Bank which is
an issue of significant concern to
Donald Trump right now visa vie the
Trump Russia probe being carried out by
robert muller so these could all just be
coincidences but it appears to stink
beyond belief it's the putrid
kleptocracy that we've been talking
about now for many years and there has
never been more swamp filling this could
be normal pay to play normal this could
be standard quid pro quo call it what
you want we see it for what it is but
it's even worse because of the
connections that this has in particular
to Donald Trump and to Russia and we may
never really learn the full scope of it
that's the most disappointing and
disturbing part let me know what you
think could this just be a coincidence
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and the show
is on Twitter at David Pakman show
viewers and listeners of the David
Pakman show with a dog or cat at home
you should check out one of our new
sponsors called pet box which is a
subscription box that sends you premium
treats and toys for your dog or cat
every month you can get 50% off your
first box when you click the link under
this video and use the coupon code
Pakman all you have to do is tell them
what kind of pet you have you tell them
how big your pet is and every month
you'll get a new bar
filled with a variety of the latest and
greatest high quality pet snacks and
toys made mostly by small family-owned
businesses it also makes a really great
gift for someone else in your life who
has a pet I just got the dog box for
Nemo the English lab my dad's dog who my
Instagram followers or maybe already
acquainted with got a bunch of really
cool stuff including pterodactyl treats
and a true jerky type thing you can tell
I don't have a dog
also a squeeze toy and the coolest thing
about pet box is that they give 10% of
the proceeds to a nonprofit called
tender loving canines which does really
good things number one they provide
service dogs to people with autism
number two they provide service dogs for
veterans who have PTSD so your pet is
getting an array of fun things to play
with and snack on every month but you're
also contributing to a really good cause
and as I mentioned you can get half off
of that first box when you click the
link underneath this video and use the
coupon code Pakman that's P a K ma n